merci et ben voilà ça y est ouais c'est
très bien et sont très contents de moi q
music les héros se retrouvent après ce
week end à rtl ça revient à berchem ça
va très bien on a rigolé ce matin on a
parlé de vous sur skyrock vous avez dit
quoi sert-elle ouais bah écoute et
honnêtement on se porte pas mal du tout
vu les circonstances on a bien de la
chance
toujours derrière france inter comme moi
la confédérati sais pas si vous êtes
derrière parce qu'elle est la première à
nous français yoplait le lait les
techniciens des amis qu est la première
radio de france
enfin terre jeudi au total israël veut
magouiller fois non mais sans déconner
la belle je veux que vous le disiez
devant le testateur quelle est la
première année rappelle jean-marc
s'appelle jean marc germond jours voilà
bah tiens à me jean marc morandini
jean-marc fois en 10 6 op france inter
démarquez vous allez lire à haute voix
[Rires]
les sorties mon chéri qu'elle est la
première à d'autres on sait juste une
question est posée
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est tout merci merci jean marc
c'est tout ce que je voulais pas nous
coucougnettes cahier la question a parlé
cyril hanouna ce matin je me rase et un
peu
là et toi mais bullish est bullish
exactement et ici je suis avec un avec
une tondeuse et tu vois pas et je
t'explique sesquières j'étais bien venez
ouais je fais une petite entaille et je
saigne la face à une beaucoup l'aimer
les policiers il ya mes parents qui
m'appellent pour aller manger j'entends
je prends les genres une serviette sur
la duke ou saison là mais je t'explique
la serviette elle était blanche a décrit
rouge au bout de toutes appelées régis
ravanas et le président le président
d'arte et alors elle va l'appeler et
elle va lui dire france inter est la
première à de transe d'accord et comme
ça des métaux blancs
oui oui alors régis et isabelle alors
encore en cours en france
[Rires]
régis j'ai quelqu'un
qui travaille pour toi qui as quelque
chose à te dire bon alors régis il
m'emmerde intérêt la première radio de
france mais on sait toi et moi que c'est
pas vrai tout à fait honnête on a été
tous et on est tous les deux numéros ils
n'ont pas voulu me croire d'où tu sais
qu'on éprouve rtn et on espère que lors
du corps quand rtl redeviendra première
à de france le poteau on va faire une
fête
attention j'ai pris de la vitesse voilà
baby loup sur tf1 et vous aviez
dézinguer tous les animateurs de tf1
vous aviez dit art toujours sans
prompteur il sait rien faire
oui il ya vous avez dit quoi d'autre
arthur - non il y avait il y avait
surtout à arturo j'avais dit que sans
prompteur ne peut pas s'en sortir et
qu'en plus on pollue pas le dire parce
que situé sur tf1 dont vous aviez
dézinguer tout vos bras camarades ouais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé racontez moi
comment ça s'est passé
il faut selon moi j'ai envie de savoir
etienne mougeotte qui m'appellent bon ok
naujac c'est le grand pas qu'on tienne
qui m'appelle il me dit bon bernard l'a
quand même tu as été fort un bon je te
comprends ouais c'est pas correct que ce
qu'on a fait mais quand même
tu as été un peu fort tu sais le les met
une pression pour te dégager
j'ai pas dégagement dégagement vous êtes
tous pareils à quelques semaines
fanny allemand une sculpteuse qui
travaillent et pour beaucoup
d'associations décide de faire un clip
pour sos inceste et s'appelle à
plusieurs personnalités dont bernard
montiel
elle me dit bon bernard j'ai tout à fait
je vous dis parce que fanni il a proposé
le clip à tf1 pour qu'ils accueillent ça
fait quinze jours qu'ils étaient en
négociation avec tf1 pour diffuser ce
clip ce qui est normal et légitime
ils étaient pas contre visiblement
amendement dit qu'il ne diffuserons
jamais ce clip
bernard cuisson douce ou triste non
sincèrement d'abord je suis très gêné
parce que ce n'était pas mon intention
c'est une très belle oeuvre
je suis très gêné de cette histoire et
je lui avais dit retirer moi ça me gêne
beaucoup d'en parler je me sens coupable
parfait non non non mais non mon bernard
si les enfants c'est horrible enfin je
veux dire mais les passages lors j'ai
dit retirer moi avec pas qu'on donne ma
voix mais attendez attendez prendre avec
4 il fallait attaquer le mal par le mal
l'année prochaine va nous mettre des
dieux comme ça toute l'émission va
beaucoup voilà dès lundi on va le
diffuser je vous le dis mon père marc il
faut sympa c'est bien vous les
appréhensions mais comme ils n'ont pas
voulu diffuser ce clip on s'est dit
qu'on allait nous diffuser un clip
devant tf1 et il ya un clip qui est bien
angoissant et qui vous prend bien la
tête
c'est bob dab dab bogdanov donc regarder
on n'a qu'à les lois de son ventre
on a près avoir un camion regarder bah
voilà regarder ces voix là on est devant
tf1 est ce qu'on peut avoir un plomb la
chauffer
voilà parce que là ya un caméo voilà
devant devant des fans voilà alors on
comprend pas la regarder regarde et vois
la regarde et vois là on est devant tf1
voilà donc on va laisser ça pendant
toute l'émission
si on ajoute à ça ne me plait favoris
n'ont pas voulu diffuser que tu vois là
et on les laissera même pendant toute la
nuit